be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
am so amped up right now I am so excited
for a couple reasons the first is
because I just uploaded my trailer my
reaction to Star Wars The Force awakens
trailer number 2 which looks amazing the
other reason is because this officially
starts our series of time runs out we're
getting into time runs out now we're
getting into the lead-up to Secret Wars
2015 which starts in like two weeks so I
am very psyched that being said in this
video we're going to focus on a Hyperion
now Hyperion this version there's
actually a standalone version he's not
tied to any of the other verses of
Hyperion that we've seen in the history
of Marvel Comics so we're not really
going to focus on them because they
don't matter right now now this version
of Hyperion is actually part of Earth
thirteen thousand and thirty-four now
for those of you guys who were new
Marvel uses numerical designations to
differentiate between the earth-616
mainstream continuity and all the other
alternate realities and so we know by
virtue of this numerical designation
here this takes place in a distant
reality from earth-616 now the way the
story of Hyperion is given to us he's
basically Marvel's version of Superman
his origin story is in fact almost
identical to the version of Superman the
difference here is he lands on a totally
different earth the way that his origin
is given to us he is apparently the I
guess the son or the child of a race of
Eternals and again we've talked about
the Eternals with regards to our
Celestials video so you're welcome to
check that out if you want to but but
basically all this really means is that
he's the son of a far advanced race the
problem was that this racist planet was
dying it was basically going to blow up
and so before it exploded he was sent
off into space and he landed on the
planet Earth in the thirteen thousand
thirty-four reality now what happens
when he lands on this earth is he's
basically adopted by a man named father
now there's a lot of things that are
left out here the way the story is given
to us by Marvel it's kind of a gloss
over of the history of Hyperion and
that's really all we need here with this
character we don't really need an
in-depth explanation because we'll see
some things that are explained to us as
time goes on with regards to his
character but the fact remains that when
he's adopted by a man named father we're
not actually given what father's name is
we don't really even know if he's an
actual father if he really exists like a
fun
they're two Hyperion or if his
involvement with Hyperion is more
instructional and I would go as far as
to say the instructional relationship
seems to be the case and the reason why
I say that is because what father does
is basically teach Hyperion what it
means to be a contributing member of
society on this version of Earth in the
thirteen thousand thirty-four reality
that Earth is far more advanced than the
one in the earth-616 continuity and so
what father basically tells Hyperion is
that it's not enough to just look at
people it's not enough to wait for a
problem to happen and then try to fix it
that he can't exist in a reactionary
measure his goal or his role in life
should be to guide society towards this
sort of utopian ideology so that when
the time comes when Humanity is ready to
step into this role of a peaceful
coexistence that they'll actually be
able to do it as opposed to struggle and
then fail and so what we find over the
course of his over the course of his
life is that eventually he forms a group
called the squadron supreme now the
squadron supreme has existed in Marvel
Comics again that's a group that doesn't
seem to be tied into this one but the
squadron supreme can best be compared to
the Avengers of the planet Earth or if
you wanted to make a DC analogy the the
Justice League of America but the fact
remains that there comes a point in the
history of the earth thirteen thousand
thirty-four reality where an incursion
happens and again those of you guys who
are new here an incursion is basically
what Marvel is using to end their entire
multiverse
that's where two earths appear in the
sky now if both earths collide then both
realities are destroyed but if one of
the earths is destroyed then both
realities survive and so what happens is
that while the earths are moving towards
each other over the course over the
course of this eight-hour window that
everybody in the squadron supreme is
killed or destroyed trying to stop the
incursion and so Hyperion is really the
only superhero left and in fact the only
survivor of his planet left and so as a
result he's physically able to keep the
earth separated simply by pushing on the
two of them but the problem is that
there's so much power so much pressure
being given off by these earths that
they both destroy I guess they both
explode anyway and as a result the
realities are destroyed along with it
and so what happens is Hyperion is
basically just confined to his own
reality which is basically a giant white
void that's really all it is and so the
result is that
in the earth-616 continuity advanced
idea mechanics the group called aim
actually reaches in to the earth
thirteen thousand thirty-four reality
and plucks Hyperion out of it now we're
not explicitly told why they do that but
given the basis of aim which is
basically a group that exists to try to
expand its own scientific knowledge this
was most likely done to simply just
explore realities and then they just
found Hyperion sitting there and as a
result they had taken him that when they
did they began kind of experimenting on
him they began sort of investigating his
properties investigating his power to
see what he was capable of but because
he draws his power directly from the Sun
again much like Superman he was
virtually powerless when he was
discovered by the Avengers now the
Avengers led by Captain America had
arrived to basically again add Hyperion
to their ranks and so they had freed
Hyperion now from here we actually
jumped forward a little bit and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna kind of
step I guess a little ahead of time
jumping into Avengers issue number 34 I
think and what Avengers issue number 34
does is it basically gives us this kind
of explanation with Hyperion in terms of
how he's trying to cope with the world
and the reason why is because Hyperion
again he comes from a place where
society was far more advanced for him
human beings on earth six one six are
very primitive and they operate in a
very primitive way and so one of the
coolest examples we get here in these
was when he's basically trying to solve
a crime when he's trying to fit in here
and what he does is he arrives at the
home of a family whose child has gone
missing and when he initially shows up
the police there are there I guess
they're already there of course
questioning the family asking them
information and different things like
that trying to figure out if they can
get a lead or not and when Hyperion
appears it basically begins to I guess
to frighten the family they begin to get
concerned the police of course are also
concerned because for them whenever
superheroes appear as a follower I guess
as a fall out of sorts to civil war the
assumption is that there's always going
to be some measure of violence and a
vast amount of destruction and so the
police just simply can't cope with that
in this small town and so what Hyperion
does is he basically bypasses the family
and the police he analyzes the carpet he
finds some DNA fragments and then he
takes to the sky and once he takes to
the sky he begins to look over every
single person that he can find and
literally scan their DNA and once he
finds the boy he takes off to meet with
the boy and the person
kidnapped him and so again we're not
going to go to in depth into the story
because at this point just kind of
breaks down to unnecessary things but
the fact remains that this is basically
Hyperion doing what he can to be an
Avenger doing what he can to fit in in a
world that in truth he doesn't really
belong in and so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna bring this video to an end
because what we'll find is that once we
get into time runs out
Hyperion is largely going to be just
kind of a mainstay of the Avengers but
once we get towards the end of time runs
out
he and Odin's son and foe are going to
get into this massive conflict that's
really going to be biblical in terms of
proportion and it's really going to
determine the fate of everything in the
multiverse with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
Oh